-Guys, it is time for "Tonight
Show Hashtags," here we go.
-♪ Hashtag ♪
♪ Hashtag ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week, where I send out
a hashtag and ask you guys to
respond to that topic.
So since it's the holidays,
people will be traveling,
I sent out the hashtag
#TravelFail.
And I asked you guys to share
some of your funniest
or weirdest stories from trips
that you've been on.
Within minutes, it was a
trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
And now I thought I'd share some
of my favorite.
These are travel fail responses
from you guys.
This first one's from
@BakeRoss1988.
He says...
Wow. Only, only seven more
hours, kids, we'll be right --
-"I'm sorry, I can't find you."
This one's from @movienerd15.
He says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
Oh, my --!
-Where's my ven doll?
Derek!
[ Light laughter ]
-"Help me."
-"Help me!"
-This one's from @teesa1980.
She says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
This one's from @MarisaRosie22
She says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
-How dare you!
Honking...
-This one is from @haats528, but
it's an extra A in the hats.
"Haats."
-Oh, "Haats."
She says...
[ Laughter ]
-Ah.
-Told the whole story in one
tweet right there.
-Yeah, it's Mitch Miller.
-Oh, here, this one is from
@eddielovestoast
-Oh, he does.
-He says...
[ Applause ]
-A man that was murdered.
-This one's from @pdb435.
He says...
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Live action movie.
-This movie's so realistic.
-You're like family.
This last one's from
@mamamarshall2
-Mamama Marshall.
She says...
There you have it. Those were
our "Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of our
favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.